total il ya quelques secondes un pauvre
de la raffinerie de donges qui va
retraités donc les déchets c'est vrai
que le 4e groupe pétrolier mondial total
fina elf a eu son image écornée par
cette histoire de pollution écologique
et en même temps a fait énormément de
bénéfices le point maintenant sur la
responsabilité et les années nidation
développé par total
monsieur s'activent dans l'atelier
pendant que madame tient la caisse
depuis dix ans ce couple gère une
station total ils se sont installés ici
dont le centre ville de nantes et il ira
non ils ont subi de plein fouet la crise
erika c'était difficile parce que on
était toujours citées dans les médias en
été on était en première ligne c'était
nous qui avions qui nettoie face aux
clients et donc c'était pas toujours
facile à gérer mais je pense qu'on l'a
fait au mieux et puis le résultat est
qu'on n'a pas perdu nos clients
malgré la catastrophe les clients sont
restés fidèles ils n'ont pas répondu aux
appels au boycott ils ont même parfois
apporté leur soutien dans les moments
difficiles je pense que ce qu'on met par
hasard sur le sur un bateau qui était
affrété par total sera pu être quelqu'un
d'autre et puis ils sont commerçants
comme moi ils ont leur clientèle à
défendre ils sont pour rien vous en avez
parlé un peu tous les deux on a on a eu
l'occasion d'en discuter les deux bien
sûr parce que bon ça le touche est quand
même il a quand même
pignon sur rue 1 il fait partie d'un
quartier où les gens connaissent ici
comme partout en france les ventes n'ont
pas baissé le client n'a pas déserté les
stations total cette année grâce à la
conjoncture le groupe pétrolier
enregistre d'ailleurs des résultats
record 22 milliards de francs sur les
six premiers mois de l'année reste de la
mauvaise image que total tente d'effacer
depuis un an avec plus ou moins de
succès le défi pour l'entreprise c'est
pas de dire il s'est rien passé on va
tout oublié non c'est de dire je mets ça
de côté et je reviendrai un jour pour
montrer qu'aujourd'hui je peux avoir la
tête haute avec les investissements que
j'ai fait pour réparer le mal qui a été
réalisé en attendant d'avoir la tête
haute la vie continue pour notre couple
de gérants et les affaires vont plutôt
bien ce jour là ils ont vendu tout leur
gaz oil jusqu'à la rupture de stock